[Musica]
questa foto
la mia montagna di sono il posto in cui
sono nata e
mi piaceva averla dietro di me perché è
da lì che vengo sono insomma le mie
radici la tradizione che mi porto dentro
parte da lì i colori sono un po
particolari non so se si notano e
abbiamo fatto uno studio sulle palette
che mi rappresentassero di più con dei
creativi che mi hanno seguito negli
ultimi mesi abbiamo estrapolato questi
due colori il giorno che ho capito che
non volevo più tenere il bisturi in mano
ma preferivo il cucchiaio di legno ai
fornelli ero fermo al semaforo a roma
sull'appia
sembra una di quelle cose epiche da
romanzo da film sentimentale anni 90
quando la protagonista all'epifania e le
cambia il corso della storia
eppure è vero è così a volte
semplicemente le decisioni migliori
della tua vita arrivano nel momento più
banale della giornata può essere un
semaforo come è successo a me quando
passi l'aspirapolvere o quando gioca col
gatto mentre continua a giocare lui
continua mordicchiarsi le mani ignora la
tua epifania dentro di te intanto
succede di tutto l'illuminazione è
incredibile e proprio in quel momento
ho capito che la carriera di medico che
avevo scelto non faceva per me
ritornava a casa dall ennesima lezione
del terzo anno avevo come il libretto
già degli esami è la mia convinzione era
che il mio mondo sarebbe poi stato in
divisa col camice e odoroso
disinfettante e invece no c'era un altro
leit motive fu un altro
odore profumo altre sensazioni che mi
sarei portata con me
la divisa bianca c'era lo stesso
ma l'indirizzo sarebbe stato
completamente diverso
si parla di effetto domino quando un
cambiamento anche minuscolo in grado di
produrne altri analoghi a propria volta
e dando origine a quella che viene
definita una sequenza linea e appunto il
domino con le sue tessere è proprio la
rappresentazione fisica perfetta sia
come gioco che come costruzione di
immaginare se ci pensiamo perché quanti
di noi si sono persi a guardare su
instagram su youtube questi video di
questi splendidi domino colorati che
compongono delle figure incredibili mano
a mano che le tessere cadono una dietro
l'altra e quanti voi cercando di far
combaciare le combinazioni matematiche
hanno visto in quelle sequenze di numeri
le stesse montagne russe dei propri
percorsi professionali un punto per ogni
decisione in scala da 0 a 6
ecco io quel giorno ho vissuto entrambe
le versioni del domino dentro di me come
se contemporaneamente avessi scartato
dallo stallo di gioco dove mancava la
tessera giusta per procedere nel
percorso e avessi anche dato il primo
colpo decisivo alla nuova tessera del
mio domino professionale
componendo qualcosa di totalmente
diverso a quanto avevo vissuto fin lì
io sono cresciuta con il concetto di
prendermi cura degli altri è sempre
stato uno dei miei valori principali
semplicemente loro applicato troppo alla
lettera scegliere un indirizzo come
medicina mi aveva approcciato a questa
cosa ma in maniera molto scientifica che
forse per me per la mia indole
nonostante fossi molto studiosa
risultava davvero molto asettico e molto
netto per quello che potevano anche
essere le mie prospettive
capendo che non era il mio modo di
prendermi cura delle persone mi stavo
finalmente liberando da quello stallo da
quella tessera storta che rischia di
interrompere il flusso regolare degli
eventi e il disegno generale
ma cambiare il gioco in corsa non è
sempre facile come sembra nei film
significa imboccare un'altra strada che
è completamente diversa e ricominciare
solo dalla propria determinazione che
poi anche il pilastro fondante delle
nostre decisioni
io quella determinazione ce l'avevo
e una delle qualità che non mi sono mai
mancate
avevo anche una buona dose di
testardaggine che i miei genitori che
sono nel pubblico potranno confermare ma
soprattutto tanta voglia di fare
qualcosa che mi rispecchiasse che mi
rendesse felice
c'è una citazione molto bella di elsa
morante ed è una domanda che la
scrittrice negli ultimi anni di vita
faceva tutti chiedendo quale fosse la
frase in grado di esprimere al massimo
il sentimento d'amore
e quindi di fronte a tante risposte poi
incentrate sul romanticismo il sogno
l'universo i massimi sistemi e st
morante rispondeva caustica che l'unica
frase l'unica vera frase d'amore era hai
mangiato
e stata questa la tessera centrale del
domino quella che poi domina il disegno
lo rende vivo come la vernice che rende
appunto speciale e brillanti colori dei
pittori
l'amore per il benessere degli altri
l'amore per il cibo il prendersi cura
delle persone attraverso questo cibo che
viene prima selezionato preparato e poi
servito a ripensarci nel corso del tempo
ci sono state molte corrispondenze di
vocabolario tra il lavoro in medicina e
quello in cucina come camici bianchi le
ricette di strumenti di precisione
verrebbe come affettare ricucire è
qualcosa con cui col senno di poi
insomma adesso sorrido
ma è scoperto così che entrambe le cose
si occupavano della necessità di cura e
di fisiologia
l'uno con il piacere di soddisfare il
bisogno di nutrizione mentre l'altro con
l'urgenza medicale di guarire
quando ho deciso di cambiare vita
pensavo che sarei stata da sola ad
affrontarla del resto non sono scelte
facili da far digerire a chi abbiamo
intorno a chi sperava di vederti con il
famoso pezzo di carta in mano una
carriera extra sicura invece di perdersi
nei meandri delle partite iva della
ristorazione
non sono scelte facili neanche per farle
capire a te stessa perché nonostante la
determinazione
e la certezza di aver trovato la tua
vera strada le difficoltà sono tante
quello che oggi sentiamo di più è che un
ambiente ostico e ostile che un ambiente
maschile e maschilista quello della
cucina
e poi dentro come si sta
una volta in un'intervista mi hanno
chiesto se davvero sentirsi forte questo
gap di genere e io qualche anno fa ormai
quasi cinque anni fa risposi che sentivo
questo gap di genere però quando dovevo
caricarmi sacchetti della farina e
quindi quello che cerco di vivere tutti
i giorni a far sì che l'unico cup che
rimanga nel mondo della cucina sia
proprio questo cioè la capacità di
sopportare la fatica fisica portata agli
estremi
ovviamente se le tessere del domino non
sono perfettamente dritte rischi di
rallentare verso la destinazione
ed è qui proprio qui che entrano in
gioco le persone che decidono di
aiutarti e puntano su di te e diventare
una chef e anche insegnato a fare
squadra a fare squadra con la mia
famiglia come insegna il mio papà che di
tanto in tanto dice a me i miei fratelli
che siamo una squadra gli amici i
colleghi e tanti professionisti anche
loro che sono delle tessere del mio
domino personale che poi hanno reso
fluido lo scorrere degli eventi hanno
anche un po ammortizzato degli
atterraggi no dopo tanti numerosi salti
nel vuoto
ci sono state persone con cui ho cercato
di costruire dei team e anche un po in
maniera improvvisata che poi si sono
rivelati anche duraturi sono delle
persone che mi hanno molto ispirata tra
cui gabriele bonci roberto liberati
michele varvera la famiglia dinari del
mio paese
giorgio e daniele antonelli di una
famosissima pasticceria che si trova sul
roma i fratelli palucci del ristorante
bar che si trova sempre su roma
i miei maestri
c'è anche un'altra ad essere importante
nella mia vita che la tessera di
creativi
persone che ho incontrato anche
relativamente poco tempo fa ma che mi
sembra di conoscere da una vita e quelli
che mi hanno spinta in qualche modo ad
aprire i miei orizzonti e soprattutto a
realizzare il mio sogno di dimostrare al
mondo che la cucina è davvero qualcosa
di multidisciplinare
c'è poi un'altra tessera speciale nel
domino del mio gusto personale
ed è quello che un po ha impostato tutta
la mia carriera e ha dato il volume è
giusto le mie aspirazioni
a che fare col cibo a che fare con la
sua memoria è un archivio immenso di
sapori di gusti di consistenze che
costituiscono la grammatica di
conoscenza del cibo
la pasta al pomodoro
o meglio il pomodoro con la pasta
e ricordo più vivido della mia infanzia
o nella mia mente sempre solo la stessa
scena
mio nonno seduto a tavola con addosso
una canottiera bianca un caldo
asfissiante perché si sa che il momento
migliore per assaporare il pomodoro non
conservato e l'estate il rumore del
cucchiaio che sbatte sul piatto è lui
che misuri da e mi dice che se mi ma
posso assaggiarlo quel soggetto finto
che lo chiamava così
e con sugo che non colorava la pasta che
appena appena cotto
l'ho interpretato e oggi lo descrivo
come un suo che sprigiona al contempo
l'odore della polpa ma che lascia
presagire la presenza dei semini perché
i semini del pomodoro li mangio
voglio ricondurre l'educazione del mio
palato a quell'episodio a una pasta
cotta forse anche troppo
un sugo tecnicamente imperfetto dialogo
more del risucchio nell'incavo del
cucchiaio
ecco dentro quel gesto
c'è la genuinità che spero di non
perdere mai nella cucina
dentro quello comune c'è la
soddisfazione di una persona che mangia
esattamente ciò che egli va di mangiare
e non il piatto fatto così perché va
fatto così
[Applauso]
per me è impressionante che ogni festa
ogni evento ogni evento importante della
vita persino l'elaborazione della sua
fine ovvero la morte
prevedo comunque la presenza del cibo
l'educazione sentimentale al mangiare e
ai sapori che poi entrano nella nostra
memoria passa attraverso i grandi fatti
della vita ea ciò che arricchisce varie
buffet
però lo sappiamo il cibo non ha soltanto
un elemento fisico ma per chi lo vive
come lo vivo io ho anche una componente
emotiva molto forte
e io lo ammetto sono sempre molto in
difficoltà quando devo tradurre questo
dettaglio sulle emozioni e una sorta di
lente semitrasparente che mi fa vedere
in maniera diversa il domino
io ho scelto il cibo proprio per amore
viscerale
ho lavorato per incanalare questo amore
nelle competenze tecniche e
professionali che portano l'elaborazione
di un piatto di un menu e poi ad alti
livelli ti permettono di gestire un
ristorante
ma cucinare per me è sempre un atto
d'amore supremo forte
alto è un po la mia lingua e la mia
espressione
cir assumo tutta me stessa
ciò che ho imparato ma soprattutto
quello che voglio diventare perché non
si finisce mai di imparare
ogni piatto che penso ogni preparazione
che assembla
ogni menù che compongo con dei criteri
di equilibrio e di varietà di sapori e
come se fosse il mio biglietto da visita
piccole attenzioni
il modo in cui vi presento le persone
che ho scritto che ospito nel mio
ristorante
e voi che mangiassero esattamente quello
che gli va di mangiare che non pensassi
l'ora sovrastruttura quale recensioni
che si sedessero e che si lasciassero
andare
e che mangiassero il gu per il gusto di
assaporare un piatto fatto con tutto
l'amore possibile
mi chiamo sarah o quasi 34 anni e sono
una cuoca e questa è la direzione che
voglio dare alle nuove tessere del mio
domino
[Applauso]